[Music]
welcome to the drama behind the scenes
show I'm your host definition and with
comic-con in full swing I thought I'd
bring you the most savage MCU panel
interview ever let me just set the scene
before we play the clip it's ace
comic-con Kevin Smith is hosting a panel
with Anthony Mackie Tom Holland and
Sebastian Stan and two fans get up to
ask them a question
and yep Anthony rocky doesn't have any
time for them whatsoever
this is absolutely hilarious so without
further ado let's dive into the clip you
weren't you the one that screamed like
one more you know it's a two-parter well
done yes what are your names everyone
give it up for Jamie what's your name
everyone give it up please take it away
ladies you're gonna bring us home and us
well here we go
I just wanted to say that um I have a
pit bull in so since tests assist a fee
that's a super cool and I love Tessa to
pet her for me I will thank you oh my
god you just shot the Winter Soldier in
her face make you have a good time on
the Internet tonight wait time out time
out how do you know who Tessa he posts
us all the time oh he's posting pictures
of him and his dog yes he's just hanging
out at home with his dog baby I'm an
adult
[Applause]
I follow no man just so you know write
it down take a picture tweet that [ __ ] I
follow nobody got a lot of free
I like that I like that she clipped your
wings Falcon I don't know the term
friends I know the term family what's up
when stuff get tight when stuff get
tight let me see where your friend will
grow a little bit you'll get there you
guys need to make up what did your
friends say tell us what your friends
say you and your friend where's iris
stand up iris great friend
and I've no I'm getting to Sebastian my
childhood nickname was Bucky so you're
like you were automatically like my
first favorite character for Marvel ever
over here since the idea of the word
question is lost on you two over here
young Wow I'm absolutely I was dying
throughout that that was basically like
watching Anthony Mackie go full Papa Doc
mode a shout out to eight-mile there you
could see the moment where her heart
literally breaks and yeah I kind of see
it from both sides you know they both
kinda were as the kids say throwing
shade at one another obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this clip and
who you think was in the right and
personally I'm definitely teamcap right
now and it's killing me a bit inside
watching how much you kind of crushed
their dreams and so leave your opinion
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out my recent
breakdown of Robert Downey jr.
confirming that Iron Man built the mark
85 for one specific reason we go over
the entire breakdown of the suit and why
Tony Stark was such a great hero in
Avengers end game so it's definitely
worth checking out after this if you
want to know more also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers end game on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on this clip in the comment
section below that one will be chosen at
random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then -
ever gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part Cheers this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and
see you next time take care peace
you